right now there's so many holiday posts  going around about how great everything  is and how thankful everybody is but  that's not everybody and that might not  be you if you're struggling right now if  you don't want to see your family if  you're dealing with trauma from your  past if you and your partner aren't  doing well it's all right  make sure you do the things that you  need to do to be well go for a walk get  some breathing in make sure you don't  overdo it on the crazy foods make sure  you find some people that you can be in  a relationship with you're worth being  well this holiday season even if it  means doing stuff a little bit different  take care of yourself you're worth it